So in the early days of this disease the first conservation management action
was to put some devils away somewhere
safe, isolated from the disease
where we could maintain a population of
healthy devils
that could be used to reintroduce them to
the wild
The rate at which Tasmanian devils have been declining throughout Tasmania
makes the threat of extinction a possible
outcome
and we're quite concerned about that and
that's where we're trying to put our efforts
and to learn more about the disease
itself.
At the moment we're working with the
genome sequence and with a large drug screen
here at the Sanger Institute
to try to identify targeted molecules which act against
specific mutated proteins in the devil cancer
which may be effective treatments for this disease.
We still have a lot of work to do but
we have researchers from
all over the world working on this
problem, in the UK and in Tasmania, in Hobart
and so, we hope that eventually we will have
something that could tip the balance
in favour of the Tasmanian devil
and give them a fighting chance to survive in the wild.